okay thank you uh for joining me on the
show today and and here we are in camden
the roundhouse your constituency now
it's sometimes said that being the
leader of the opposition
is the hardest job in politics
but you're looking quite relaxed today
and it's not just your jeans it's not
just your dress down thursday we're in
camden and we're in camden we're in your
home patch um but you you're looking
pretty relaxed you seem pretty relaxed
at pmq's this week is that because of
the tory leadership race
i think it a combination really
obviously
um having gone through
a really hard few years in the labour
party it is very nice to be seeing the
conservative party tearing itself apart
and providing me with such brilliant
material to attack them
but there's a slightly
wider feeling
of well being the labour party at the
moment because after
two hard years
of leadership we've got ourselves with
the local elections
and the wakefield by-election into a
position where
what
we had back then was
a hope yeah that we might win the next
election that's turned into a belief
yeah that we'll win that next election
and that i think has built a sort of
confidence and inner confidence in
ladies it's something that wasn't there
until it's almost it's almost when you
took over everyone you're the guy that's
going to get the party ready you're
going to lose the next general election
and then there'll be someone that
succeeds you that gets to bpm and you
were going to do the hard graft someone
else was going to enjoy the spoils yeah
do you almost believe now do you agree
with that that you kind of might have
thought that yourself a bit well when i
took over two years
um and two or three months ago
most people said
good luck here
yeah um
and then behind my back but not nasty
they sort of said but you're never going
to do it in one term you can't get the
labour party from where it landed in
2019 worst election results since 1935
et cetera um
to win an election did you sort of think
that too no i come on i never did
actually didn't you i knew what we had
the audacity of hate to change and
continue to change the party which we've
been you know working so hard on needed
to expose the tourists what they were
unfit to govern and then say well if not
then then why are i never thought we
couldn't do it but this year you can
feel it people are thinking you know
what
there's a belief now that we can is it
also because um
you found boris johnson's going and you
found him quite difficult you did find
him a difficult opponent right he was
kind of like stardust and
you found it hard did you to tackle him
it wasn't so much hard i
i really
disliked the fact that
he was prime minister of the country he
had
such an opportunity to do good things to
make the change that we needed and he
wasn't doing any of it uh that's those
sort of empty promises never delivering
slogans but nothing behind them that
really frustrated me and that that's not
just a party political point by the way
there are conservative leaders theresa
may as someone i worked with when i was
director's public prosecutions she was
home secretary now i may have disagreed
with her politically but she had a sense
of what the job was the change he needed
to bring about and he didn't happen so
to this prime minister not pull the
levers and make the changes who would
you rather face across the dispatch box
leaving party issues aside which of
those two people does the national
interest required to be a leader i
really don't mind i really don't mind
who do you think would be better for the
country
i don't think either of them because
i think it's a mistake to think that
the change that we need now is just to
change at the top of the tory party
we've had 10 years
of stagnation and tries to think
what are most people most families
what's their emotion and i think most
people say i'm worse off i'm cutting
back and this has been going on a very
very long time and and so
they can't bring about the change that
we need in the country also just just
before i go on are you also more relaxed
because the durham case is over you were
exonerated
how did that feel for you the moment
that the police announced that
investigation was it a mouth go dry
moment for you you knew you must have
known in that moment
god i'm gonna have to resign if they
find me
was it horrible it must have been awful
it was a really big moment when they
made their decision
um i was confident that we hadn't broken
i know i'm not how did it make you feel
you must have been nervous frightened
did you think god it's all about to go
wrong for me i was i really hated it uh
if i'm honest that being subject to a
criminal investigation
when you've been the director of public
prosecutions i hated it
um and you know i'm not like other
people in many respects who may say well
that it doesn't really matter i did you
know it was re it really meant a lot to
me it was a burden
um that i was carrying i'm trying not to
show it of course
um but it was you know it was there
every day and of course i was massively
pleased when the decision came through
completely exonerated what did you say
to vic your wife when it happened what
did she say to you a lot of people
when i took the decision criticized me
for taking two or three days to take the
decisions you may remember
because
i put my whole career on the line
everything i've ever done i've been a
lawyer i've worked in northern ireland
i've been director of public
prosecutions i've been an mp leader of
the lobe party and i put all of that on
the line and i wasn't going to do that
until i'd sat down as i did on that
sunday and talked it through with vic my
wife because a huge decision to take
i took it as a matter of principle
because i thought strongly that those
who make the rules can't break the rules
i also wanted to show that not all
politicians are the same
because i think that is very corrosive
and the delay was my fault it wasn't the
people have blamed me or the team and
said why didn't you get out quicker why
did you make the nine o'clock
but but i i knew i wanted i need to sit
down on my own with vic with vic and say
this is what i'm
going to do
you know what do you think about it is
it the right decision i am literally
putting everything on the line
for a principle that i believe in but
it's going to have a huge impact on us
and that's what the sunday was all
about you must have known on friday
that's what you're gonna have to do but
you what you're saying is you had to
check it with her yeah i was up in the
northwest of the country when that
decision came through i got the train
back that afternoon and i knew in my gut
what i was gonna do
vic knew what i was going to do
um and she supported me through it
you aren't you're still not cutting
through and
labor are doing well in the opinion
polls
but you're doing quite badly in terms of
personal ratings what what's going on do
you think well look
we need to put this in its perspective i
think in a proper context
we picked up the labour party two years
ago having lost a very very badly in the
election and nobody thought we could win
the next election
now the challenge i'm getting is why
aren't you further ahead in the polls
people need to remember that two years
ago they're saying to me you're not even
going to get into that position here so
i yeah
you know when i reflect on the two years
what are the things i need to do better
and differently one of them is to try
and blank out some of the noise some of
the time and just keep focused on the
job in hand members of the public and
this is a poll on june 13th jail
partners that members of the public
think you are
boring bland and dull
it's not very easy for me to say that to
you because it feels a bit rude but
that's what i mean does that hurt you
when
and you said ah no i'm not i mean what
what what's happening that
who you are doesn't seem to connect
or are you a bit boring i don't know
i don't think i am i don't think you
think i am uh beth but um
i'm not going to pretend that i think
that politics is a branch of the
entertainment business it's not running
the country is a really serious issue
and you need serious politicians to do
it one of the frustrations the last
12 years is that we haven't had a
serious strategy for growing our economy
taking the opportunities of the future i
think we need that what i like is when
we get out we go around the country talk
to people where they are whatever
they're doing
great interactions whether it's people
communities businesses etc and i often
say to them what what do you want from a
government what's the thing that you
want most and none of them say to me oh
we need a bit more entertainment
we need a few one-liners they say i want
someone serious who understands my life
is showbiz in a way
in a way he was showbiz and he was
hugely successful
so i mean in a telegenic age maybe you
do need a bit of entertainment in
politics i don't know was he hugely
successful well i mean he was
electorally successful he won an
election and i i'm not i'm not failing
to acknowledge that of course i
acknowledge that
um and that was very successful he got
an 80-seat majority
years and what seven months out after
that
he is
um
removed from office by his own side in
disgrace i mean if you take david
cameron or or theresa may
they left office but because of big
policy disagreements he's left office in
disgrace i don't think that's a success
two two and a half years or so
since an election
win you're kicked out of office because
nobody trusts that's not my definition
let me put it let me put it another way
to you because i'm not asking you to be
kind of provocative i'm actually asking
you because it seems to be a barrier in
your ability
to win people over i mean do you think
there's something you need to change
about yourself or do you think it's more
that you need to stop being a lawyer and
start being a bit more of a politician
and what i mean by that is you seem to
weigh all your words so carefully when
you're on camera at the dispatch box and
is it because you're worried about
messing up that words count in a court
of law in a way they don't perhaps count
as much in normal conversation well you
know words matter and i do think quite
carefully about what i say and um but
actually when we're out of the formal
setting
we have all sorts of conversations in
lots of different ways you know do i
need to change the way i am that we all
need to um change the way we are all of
the time but in the end what matters to
me is you know do you believe in
um the mission of an incoming labour
government and the answer is yes do i
know what i need to do yes i do and
um how do i
i mean i came into politics um later
than most people i'm learning
outside of politics
in almost every other walk of life
there's always going to be challenges
and whether you're an individual whether
in an organization within business you
you identify with the promise and you
fix it and that's my mindset what about
another reason the public might feel
unsure about you
is that they can't decide what you
believe and the reason i say that is you
spent years trying to get jeremy corbyn
into government now you seem to
completely repudiate the left you
acknowledge that's difficult for the
public
that you were trying to get this guy
into power and now you're kind of
disowning everything it was about in
2019 in that general election did you
want to see a corbyn led government with
every fiber of your being i wanted
labour government of course i did i
wanted a labour government but my focus
is on the next election
people the reason i'm asking is that
members of the public might look and go
hang on this guy was happy to have
jeremy corbyn as the leader he wasn't
worried about nashville then you do your
big thing on nato it's like what's he
about he's he's flip-flopping i'm about
me i'm about what i need to be um the
prime minister i want to be of our
country and the change we've done in
labor party has been profound dealing
with anti-semitism making it absolutely
clear that national security matters
that our support for nato is unshakable
building a new relationship with
business so one issue it struck me
over the strikes the rmt strikes
it was watching labour politicians tie
themselves in knots about did labour
back the strikes or didn't they back the
strikes what on earth was going on why
did you not take a clear position
well the position i took um was clear
and that was very very straightforward
which is
i didn't want the strikes to go ahead
yeah
that is the position that actually many
of those who were striking or likely to
strike wanted that want it resolved yes
um to say of course i understand the
frustrations of those who've had wages
that have not gone up in many cases for
a long time got a cost of living crisis
but what i wanted was the government to
step out i get that no it's really
important because that wasn't the
question the question was what the
question my position was the question
was my position that labour at no point
would say we do or don't support the
strikes you can say i don't want the
strikes to happen
but when they are happening the question
was does the labour party support the
rmt going onto the picket line or
doesn't it and it's a really simple
question and i just watched labour
politicians tie themselves in not
because presumably
you didn't want to upset the unions but
you also knew that the public were upset
about the strikes is that what was going
on one of the problems we've had in the
lab party for a long time now
is that
we envisaged ourselves as in opposition
the whole time we have to get in the
mindset of being in government if you're
in government this was what i said to my
shadow cabinet when we had the
discussion about the stripes if you're
in government and you're on the cabinet
table then you have to resolve these
issues you have to make sure that the
negotiations complete successfully mark
drakeford in wales did that he brought
the people together the parties together
and resolved the issue that's the role
of government before we stop i've got to
ask you this because we're at the
roundhouse in camden now lots of people
might not know this
you're quite a talented musician aren't
you uh well i was
like
what's the best gig you've ever been to
in the roundhouse
you're thinking i haven't been i haven't
been through oh orange juice i mean my
all-time favorite band played here
i don't i don't know orange juice
yeah
uh edward collins orange juice
rip it up
i don't know this is that they were here
but we went to see a deli other day with
the kids oh did she absolutely fantastic
yeah uh two or three weeks to see
coldplay you're going to see my wife's
absolute favorite now
so you coldplay adele
the other thing that people might
not know about you some things they
might not know you play football with
your friends once a week you take your
boy to arsenal matches and my girl now
well yeah and you get when you once your
daughter was younger you used to
pick her up from school
and used to organize your diary around i
don't think people might not know that
about you but this job your job is
totally encompassing you it can destroy
your marriage it can destroy your life
it can take over
did you ever harbour any ambiguity about
wanting to do this job
because of the impact on your family and
your family life that's the hardest bit
is the impact it has
um on my family it's the bit i worry
about the most it's why we never name
our children in public
it's why vic my wife doesn't do
interviews because
i want to protect them as best i can
because you know of course i'm in the
public eye that's the nature of the job
but it does take a toll on them we do
have some rules you know i try to ensure
that every friday by six o'clock i'm
home and i'm just there for vic and the
kids what did you do did you put your
phone in the bin or something well put
it in a job
but we do we get a takeaway on a friday
we have a family often fixed dad will
come over sometimes we do friday night
prayers with him um but um we then argue
about whether we're gonna watch
something on the television the kids
will be on their laptops
well vic's family is jewish
and so
her
dad
likes to have the friday night prayers
and um uh so we do that occasionally not
religiously everywhere you're not
religious yourself no but we want our
children to understand his jewish
um you know family
uh they came from poland we want them to
raise the children
no we don't but we want them to know
um that rick's family is jewish and to
know the traditions and the history to
understand you know what is part of
their family obviously now
one final question i've really run out
of time and everyone's sorry to wind up
um
tony blair gordon brown
um actually he's actually not gordon
brown but tony blair
and kinnick they they did you sort of
have their families more in the public
eye and you said it's a conscious
decision not but
you know when people sort of talk about
who is kirsten with a person
isn't your family like your biggest
asset in a way
yeah and vic is fantastic and everybody
who's seen or met vic says you know
she's fantastic and she is fantastic
absolutely fantastic
but i don't want you know we don't want
our family destroyed by all of this
of course it's a difficult one to get
right but
um you know i didn't we didn't have
children as sort of props in my
political life that's not why we had
kids we had kids because we wanted to
have a family of our own well kirsten i
should let you go because it's nearly
the weekend you've got to get home for
friday night thank you so much for
coming and talking to us on the show
today i appreciate it thanks for having
me thank you
and if you scan this qr code on your
screen now you can watch all of our
interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show